Speaker 1: Let's talk about one of the most
controversial candidates in the 2024 primary
field, the Democratic presidential primary. I'm
talking about robert f kennedy jr. Now, as a
reminder, bobby kennedy jr is the son of robert f
kennedy. Robert f kennedy was assassinated while
running for president. An extraordinarily gifted
politician was Robert F Kennedy. Bobby Kennedy Jr
is also the nephew of former President John F
Kennedy, who was, of course, also assassinated
while serving as president. So Bobby Kennedy comes
from this political dynasty that has impacted
American political history for a very long time.
Environmental lawyer, activist who has fought
for clean water and renewable energy and climate
justice, has a long record of advocacy for really
important issues poverty, civil rights, health
care, democracy, things that he truly inherited
from his late father, Robert Kennedy. And he's
a super interesting candidate and a nice guy who
I've met I had dinner with. We have many friends
in common. And also he has become a very powerful
anti-vaccine voice. He says he's not against
vaccines, but simply for tested and safe vaccines.
But when we actually look at the disinformation
that he has spread not only about vaccines,
but also talking about hydroxychloroquine as if
it's proven to work for Koby. I mean, there's a
long list of concerning stuff from Bobby Kennedy
Jr. He's made concerning comments about Russia
and Ukraine taking some sort of strange, softly
pro-Putin perspectives. He has talked about. He's
actually talked about gay frog said I'm talking
about Bobby Kennedy Jr here, not Alex Jones.
And he also I mean just as another example, he's
made wild, unsubstantiated claims about China. He
recently said on Newsmax, of all places, that
China is developing a racist bioweapon that
targets people based on ethnicity. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: But what I worry about is, is a WMD
like a virus, like a gain of function, something.
Do you worry about that? Because I see that as
sort of the next the next big fight because,
you know, those viruses don't see any borders
and and they're relatively cheap to do this gain
of function. I mean, it's just so that's what I
worry about more than the big hardware, right?
Speaker 3: Yeah, you're exactly right. And we
know that the Chinese are developing ethnic
bioweapons bio weapons that are designed to
attack people of certain racial types.
And the and we're doing the same thing.
Speaker 1: Okay. So does he provide any evidence
that that's happening? He does not. Is there any
evidence that I was able to find? No, I was able
to find some conjecture about this from last month
also without evidence. But I was not able to find
any evidence that that's going on. Is it possible
that you could make a racist bioweapon? It might
be possible. So. So like an ethnic bioweapon,
hypothetically, which targets people of
specific ethnicities or races or genotypes
could conceivably be created. But experts and
officials say it's it's not totally clear that
you could do it. You might be able to genetically
engineer some pathogen to target DNA markers that
are specific to some racial or ethnic group. Maybe
like maybe it could be done. Another possibility
would be like a gene therapy that creates a virus
to target particular DNA sequences. But there are
many. Forget about the ethical challenges. Let's
assume the ethics. Go out the window. There are
some insane technical challenges to do this, and
one of them is the one that often comes up in
debates about IQ. There is such genetic diversity
within ethnic groups that such a technology
would be extremely difficult to actually do.
I'm not saying it's impossible, but right now,
extreme hurdles and no evidence that
it's being done. But Bobby Kennedy says,
Oh, this thing is happening. Another example,
Bobby Kennedy Jr is hosting a so-called health
policy roundtable featuring unhinged conspiracy
theorist Sherry Tenpenny. Sherry Tenpenny is this
person. I don't want to get into the whole
osteopathy thing. She's an individual who
happens to be an osteopath who has made all sorts
of insane claims about everyone you know is soon
going to be dead from the COVID vaccine and all of
these other things. So how do we what do we make
of Bobby Kennedy Jr. Is he a viable challenger
to joe Biden? Should we support or oppose him?
For me, the situation is pretty clear. Bobby
kennedy jr is articulate, articulate and smart.
He delivers really powerful speeches even with the
struggles of his voice with spastic dysphonia. He
still delivers very powerful speeches. He appeals
to emotion and reason in a way that clearly
resonates with people. He has a personal story
and a family legacy that can be inspirational
to voters. He's right on many issues. When
you look at health care and Green New Deal,
minimum wage, criminal justice reform, voting
rights expansion, ending wars. Bobby Kennedy jr
is right on many issues. On the other side, he is
dangerously unhinged in some areas. The promotion
of unproven conspiracy theories, the pseudo
science. This stuff really undermines some of
the core structures that go towards public health
and national security. He seems disconnected with
reality, quite frankly, on some of those issues.
He will often attack fellow Democrats who happen
to disagree with him on some of these issues. He's
supported by a super PAC tied to MAGA. He seems
to be gaining support from folks on the right
who see him merely as a chaos agent potentially
to derail Joe Biden and put a hardcore right
winger in the Oval Office. So. On the one hand,
there is much to like about Bobby Kennedy. Jr
In some sense I would love to support the guy,
but based on his current positions, I don't
think that that's something that I can do.
I also don't think he can win the nomination nor
the general election with the views that he has.
He may be able to he may be able to damage Joe
Biden, but I don't believe that he has a path
to the Democratic nomination. Nor am I convinced
that this point that he would have a path to the
presidency if he somehow got on the ballot. Let
me know your thoughts. I am not just laughing h